[Music]
your hands up close are anything but
smooth with peaks and valleys folds and
rifts there are plenty of hiding places
for a virus to stick if you then touch
your face the virus can infect you but
there are two extraordinarily simple
ways you can keep that from happening
soap and water and hand sanitizer so
which is better
the corona virus that causes kovat 19 is
one of many viruses whose protective
outer surface is made of a lipid bilayer
these lipids are pin shaped molecules
whose heads are attracted to water and
tails are repulsed by it so in water
rich environments lipids naturally form
a shell like this with the heads outside
and the tails inside their shared
reaction to water makes the lipids stick
loosely together this is called the
hydrophobic effect this outer structure
helps the molecular machinery of the
virus break through cellular membranes
and hijack our cells but it has
thousands upon thousands of weak points
where the right molecules could pry it
apart and this is where soap comes in a
single drop of any brand of soap
contains quadrillions of molecules
called amphiphiles which resemble
biological lipids their tails which are
similarly repulsed by water compete for
space with the lipids that make up the
virus's shell but they're just different
enough to break up the regularity of the
virus's membrane making the whole thing
come crashing down those amphiphiles
then form bubbles of their own around
particles including the viruses RNA and
proteins apply water and you'll wash
that whole bubble away hand sanitizers
work less like a crowbar and more like
an earthquake
when you surround a coronavirus with
water the hydrophobic effect gives the
bonds within the membrane their strength
that same effect also holds the big
proteins that form coronaviruses spikes
in place and in the shape that enables
them to infect your cells if you dry the
virus out in air it keeps its stability
but now surround it with a high
concentration of an alcohol like the
ethanol or isopropanol found in most
hand sanitizers
this makes the hydrophobic effect
disappear and gives the molecules room
to move around the overall effect is
like removing all of the nails and
mortar from a house and then hitting it
with an earthquake the cell's membrane
collapses and those spike proteins
crumble in either method the actual
process of destroying the virus happens
in just a second or two but doctors
recommend at least 20 seconds of
hand-washing because of the intricate
landscape that is your hand soap and
sanitizer need to get everywhere
including your palms fingertips the
outsides of your hands and between your
fingers to protect you properly and when
it comes to a corona virus outbreak
doctors recommend washing your hands
with soap and water whenever possible
even though both approaches are
similarly effective at killing the virus
soap and water has two benefits first it
washes away any dirt which could
otherwise hide virus particles but more
importantly it's simply easier to fully
cover your hands with soap and water for
20 seconds of course
hand sanitizer is more convenient to use
on the go in the absence of a sink use
the sanitizer as thoroughly as possible
and rub your hands together until
they're dry unfortunately there are
billions of people who don't have access
to clean drinking water which is a huge
problem at anytime but especially during
an outbreak researchers and aid groups
are working to provide solutions for
these communities
one example is a device that uses salt
water and a car battery to make
chlorinated water that kills harmful
pathogens and is safe for hand-washing
so wherever possible soap and water are
recommended for a corona virus but does
that mean it's best for every viral
outbreak not necessarily many common
colds are caused by Rhino viruses that
have a geometric protein structure
called a capsid instead of a lipid
membrane the capsid doesn't have nearly
as many weak points where soap
amphiphiles can pry it apart so it takes
longer for soap to be effective however
some of its surface proteins are still
vulnerable to the destabilizing effect
of hand sanitizer in this and similar
cases
hand sanitizer may be more effective
especially if you then wash your hands
to remove residual particles the best
way to know which to use for any given
outbreak is to do what's best for all
things illness related follow the advice
of accredited medical professionals need
help timing 20 seconds of hand-washing
start now Wow nice clean hands you have
oops don't touch your face you look
well-rested have you been stretching
must be on that water you're drinking
hmm
happy birthday - I don't think we have
the copyright on that well happy
birthday forget the words has it been 20
seconds yet
hike
[Music]